[Music]
depending on the pathway analysis
approach that you use to analyze your
data
that can have a dramatic impact on the
type of insights that you're able to
derive from your results
let's look at how these different
analysis approaches differ from one
another
the first and most common approach is
what's called over representation
analysis
it's most commonly referred to as
enrichment analysis
this is a very simple but powerful
technique that leverages simple
statistics to identify pathways that may
be significant given your data
the other benefit to this particular
approach is that it doesn't require very
much input data
you can submit a short list of genes
that you're interested in and you'll get
a list of pathways that are enriched for
that set of genes
the downside to this method is that it
makes an assumption on the background of
those genes
because you only submitting a short list
of genes it has to make an assumption of
what is the denominator
for example if you have a hundred
significant genes the system might not
know what was the total number of genes
that has been analyzed
in other word is it hundred significant
genes out of ten thousand
twenty thousand or is it fifty thousand
so it makes some assumptions on that
the other downside to this method is
that you end up throwing away about
ninety percent of your data
for example if you've done an expression
experiment where you have observations
for 20
000 genes usually there's only about a
thousand or two thousand that you're
interested in
out of that entire set that is a major
disadvantage because you spend a lot of
time
and money in getting those measurements
the biggest limitation of this method
is that it assumes that all of the genes
in the pathway are independent
it completely ignores the interactions
among genes within the pathway
this can lead to a lot of false
positives
a slight improvement on enrichment
analysis approach is what's called
functional class scoring
you may have encountered gene set
enrichment analysis or gsea
which was pioneered by the broad
institute in this particular model
it is more accurate than the simple
enrichment model because in this method
we're going to use the entire list of
genes that were measured
in the case of gene set enrichment
analysis we will also supply the p
values and supply them a ranked order
depending on the type of functional
class scoring method
you may provide some weighted scoring
based on those p-value
but because this is still based on an
enrichment model it is still going to
ignore the interactions among the genes
on the pathway
it is still a count-based model and as a
result this method can lead to a lot of
false positives
in the mid 2000 a completely different
type of approach was proposed
its goal was to mimic how we think about
pathways from a biological perspective
in this case we're trying to identify
how perturbed a pathway is given a
particular input
we can do that by leveraging the
topology of the pathway
in this particular method we're going to
consider each gene's role
their position the magnitude of change
between our two phenotypes
and the interactions among other genes
in that particular system
one of the advantage about this
particular model is that it's able to
predict what's going to occur in that
system given the observations from the
data
however there are also some downsides to
this method
first it requires more data in this
particular model
we need to have measurements for all of
the genes between the two phenotypes
their measured fold change and their p
value
when this method was proposed that was a
very difficult and expensive task
but with advents and improvements in
transcriptomics in proteomics technology
and bioinformatics it is a much easier
to accomplish
this method does take slightly longer
than the enrichment models
the enrichment models can be calculated
in the matter of seconds or less but the
topology-based model is very
computationally intensive
and takes anywhere from five to ten
minutes to calculate